thank you so it's a pleasure being here
thank back to thank the organizers for
inviting me so I changed the title of my
talk from a complete classification of
multiple tight entanglement to the
little we know it seems more perhaps
closer to the truth so this my talk is
based on a paper that I got together
with Nolan wallet from UCSD and what
I'll do I'll start today is I want to
start with some notations that we use in
quantum physics and quantum information
so it would be clear what we're talking
about the I'll be using constantly this
notation zero to stand for one zero
vector in situ and this is the one and
the dual vectors are we denote them is
by a block so this is called a bar and
this is a cap and any qubit when we say
qubit what we mean we mean a vector in
situ that we write like that
and typically it's normalized the vector
is normalized will I be I mean over the
complex everything I'll talk about today
is over the complex field and of course
the dual is looking like that so this is
the piece I of Schroedinger it's simply
a vector and this vector encode
information about the spin of a physical
system or any other information but we
can think about it as spin and the
meaning of this zero here can represent
spin in the up direction and one can I
present spin in the down direction and
then this vector representing that
exists a measurement that I can do and
there is some probability to get up and
some probability to get down and there
is ways to to calculate those things but
we want I won't go into it in details
but what I I will talk about is
and other notations that we're using we
call it a partial place so we're looking
at the vector in cm tensile CN and any
vector like that is cm times Oceanus is
a morphic to M by n complex matrices
this is the matrix a so I would like to
define something that's called partial
place that with placing out the system a
a represents here Alice we typically
thinking we have two parties sharing a
quantum system
Alice holds one system and Bob holds
another system the dimensions don't have
to be the same and then we define the
partial trace for example if I'm placing
over Bob system what it is what it does
to this vector it makes it into a matrix
and the matrix is called the reduced
density matrix it's a matrix suggest a
style a well a is not a lease it's a
sorry I realized I'm using a here this a
is this matrix here a IJ so this is
adding the density matrix now we're
saying that a state small today talked
about entangled state entangled state is
any state that is not product if it's a
vector so here we have this vector I'll
be talking only about vectors and
matrices and a product is not entangled
but anything else is entangled and a
maximally entangled state is a state for
which either the partial trace are
either the reduced density matrix of
Alice all the reduced density matrix of
Bob is proportional to identity okay so
we think this is maximally entangled if
either this all this is identity okay so
that's this is the terminology I hope
it will be clear so now I want to before
going into classifying entanglement I
want to tell you to give you kind of a
little bit of an overview on what we
know about maximally entangled states
those type of states at I I described
before but this time suppose that we
have several systems I can think about
them the electrons electrons are not
necessarily green but I some reason I
like to think about them as green and
they are entangled so this circle here
represents that there are somehow
correlated the the information because
quantum state essentially encode
information about the system so a system
with the number we have several qubits
and each qubit can be correlated with
the other qubits we say that a system is
maximally into a state is maximally
entangled if when I look at it as a
bipartite card so maybe I'll write down
here what I mean so I never said yes you
are you cook you Big Sur
oh why I am walking with qubit you beat
it quantum bit because that's the
building of the rock of yes so let's
think for simplicity on qubits if it's
not a qubit if it's a three dimensional
we call it Q treat and other after that
we don't have names for every number so
we call it Q dete if it's higher than 3
and we denoting so suppose I have a
system of several cubic qubits right so
I have several qubits maybe N and now we
want to know what is a maximally
entangled so maximally entangled meaning
that every qubit he is maximally
entangled with the rest what does it
mean it means that if I
look at it like that like a bipartite
cut thinking about all of this as some C
n then I have to system right and and
then maximally entangled is just like I
defined before if the state of the
system that so if I have a state sigh
here
it belongs to here I think about it in C
to tens of C and then I say that it's
maximally entangled if I trace out this
system and I get a density matrix that
is proportional to the identity okay so
that's the definition now both of course
it's not the same dimension so it can
never be proportional to the identity if
I have more than only one of them would
be proportional if I go if I go
backwards smaller the smaller value I
don't see typically if this is not the
same dimension one of them is only yeah
so but maximally entangled thats not
enough we also require that any two of
the qubits satisfies that the same story
and III also maximally entangled and so
on so any bipartite card the smaller one
will be proportional to the identity
this is the definition of a maximally
entangled State the way I define it here
and now the question is do we have
examples of such states we do in three
cubits maybe I'll ask you did anyone can
think of which state in 3 Q between c2
tens of C to tens of c2 and so what we
are looking for is the state in this
system that if I trace out any two I get
maximally entangled and so there it's
actually the state that we lied is
called the GH this state for reasons in
physics that we have it
it has been used to to show that quantum
physics predict certain things that we
can predict in in classical physics tell
me that it's fundamentally different but
for us we're going to look at it what is
this state means that perhaps in
notations I should also mention that
whenever we denote zero zero what we
mean by that is just like one zero
corresponds to one zero and then tens oh
just one zero so it's just a short
notation for for this okay so this will
be this is the notations I'll be using
and so if I've three it's just another
tangle so this state one can see that if
you trace out any two qubits you get
something proportional to the identity
what about four cubits
it doesn't exist there is no such say
that if you trace out the reason because
if I have folk you bit well it's hard to
see the reason exactly but if we have
folk you bit your the requirement is not
just that everyone is maximally
entangled but also every by Papa every
bipartite card should be maximally
entangled so it's e to tens of C to
Denzel C to tens of C 2 so we want also
bipartite cut like that which is
fallback for two to be maximally
entangled it doesn't exist there is no
such state but in five qubit it does
exist
and it's unique exists only one such
state it is written here like that it's
used this this type of states has lots
of very nice properties and it's used in
error correcting code it's called the
five cubed code state because it's we
can use it to collect one qubit one
arrow and the way we define it the here
it's 0 0 0 0 is just again it C Sub Zero
it's the standard basis things of itself
this bracket here corresponds to a
cyclic permutation so adding it's just
because I didn't want to write a very
long state
it just means 1 1 0 0 0 plus 0 1 1 0 0
plot it like the 1 1 just got so there
are 5 terms here
it's cyclic five terms in each of those
and it has to be normalized so I divide
by like for this state is the unique
what not what I mean by unique of course
unique I mean up to local unit alleys so
if I apply an element of su 2 times su 2
or not su I mean can be u so up to up to
an element
like that five times up to local this is
what we call local unitl is up to an
element like that this state is is
unique yes yeah but it's you can do the
permutation but you can achieve it by
local unity so everything that you can
get is after local unit so this is not a
generic answer no no this state is so
you're saying if you take a generic
answer it does not have this property
but your tensor does yeah so this is a
polynomial condition it looks like
because you know this no no that's
actually if it's an it we will talk
about polynomials in a second but this
state actually give you a maximum on
your not only that it's not vanish oh
honey no and okay now I understand yeah
now I understand because I thought you
had left a great action but you only
have conjugation yeah generic will have
distinct eigen values whereas multiple
the attendant is special
so now what about six also exists only
one and it's being we can build it from
this state actually so after local unit
alley it's also known to exist and again
when I say it's unique every time I say
unique it's up to local unit out so it's
unique and we can build it like that
we're taking this one and then the note
of this which is just everywhere I see
zero I put one everywhere I see one I
put zero on this state I put it here and
look at tensile product like that that's
also unique geometric description of the
state salami so let's take the UM you
two to the fifth orbit closure of that
state right that's some algebraic
variety right answers what do you have a
description of that variety other than
as this orbiting closer for the
dimension of it yeah it's very high
that's the well it can't be that
no no yeah yeah yeah that's yeah but I
mean it's it's very quickly what I meant
is the more you increase the number of
qubits in general it's goes
exponentially high so that particular I
don't know maybe you're just adding a
you a copy of you to each dimension um
so the direction you can it grow it
looks body - yeah
so and I guess so once again they're
coming the dimensions lady all Beach and
LSU under you - yeah you're looking at
the obits underneath - you're only
interested in this up see up to the five
cops let's just stick a mic you this
really interested in it up to the action
of you two to the fifth yes
so I'm saying let's take the you two to
the fifth orbit closure of this I'm
gonna get a geometric object right
identify that geometric object in some
way other than as the orbits let's say I
give you a state than I ask you is this
maximally entangled right so this one
kind that you will need to identify that
it lies in the orbit of that right is
there some way that you know of
identifying whether it is or it is not
in the orbit closure of this of this
relations yeah the equations the way I
will do it yeah yeah I'm not sure but
I'll say that the way I understand it if
you give if you give me a state have a
very simple way to test if it's if it's
on that on other is the equation I'm
just tracing out any number of qubits
and I check and in fact it's enough to
check tracing out the the bigger sets so
like I can look here and all to like say
info cube it's have a look at our two
versus two so there are three options
and I check if these traces is identity
or not then you said that doesn't exist
two before so yeah yeah yeah I know
existent exist so in the fall it would
be any two three in the six it will be
only three three I I don't need to go on
the smaller ones because if the bigger
ones are satisfied a proportional to
identity obviously the lower ones but I
don't know if this that wasn't the
question again sir
I know what the equations aren't just
the projection onto the traceless is ya
zero but you want to know that that
mention the dimension but for example
the first one the dimension of the EOB
I don't know so for the gkd state there
is the hyper determinant that's gonna
tell you whether it is in tango
determinant is is will tell you
typically what is generic like generic
entanglement yeah it will typically tell
you which but there are many measures
the hyper determinant can be zero but
the state still entangled I see I see
yeah do you know if it's the orbit of a
wait state never be stationary so
relation that that is kind of its not
highest weight because that's kind of
description for something yeah I I don't
know on that one in fact what I we
interested is actually in the SL orbit
not so much the su because the su is as
we will see is more su has much is much
more complex I will say in to classify
all these are orbiting the yourself so I
mean the su then this oh okay so as I
said 6 cubits in seven cubits we don't
know the answer is that we don't know
if such a state exists and early claims
show that for bigger than seven it does
not exist so this is kind of just to
give us a picture of what's going on
just in terms of maximally entangled
states so what I'd like to do now is to
talk about what we know in how do we
classify entanglements so this was just
maximally entangled States now I want to
discuss how we classify entanglement in
in quantum information and typically
there is a set of operations is called
local populations and classical
communications or we call it in short
LOC C which is a very restrictive type
of operation that tells you what you can
do if you want to convert a state to
another state or a system what you can
do to a system and it turns out that a
better way to study entanglement is to
look what we can do under stochastic
operations which means I can convert one
state to another state in some
probability so there's some probability
nonzero probability that I can convert
one to another and that is called SLO
CCS so it's basically local operations
but it's not enough that they are local
they are also not not deterministic ones
so what do we think what is entanglement
I'll go by entanglement entanglement
means global coalition right so it's
some sort of correlation but it's not
classical correlation right so the way I
am this we define entanglement is by
what cannot generate it what cannot
generate entanglement local operations
cannot generate and language because
they are not global also classical
communication
cannot generate entanglement because
it's not one to so anything that the
under local operation and classical
communication this is a low CC that is
monotonic under those transformation
local operation and classical
communication I cannot increase the
entanglement so any measure of
entanglement is a mono monotone under
loc see that's a definition entanglement
is is a property of the physical system
that you cannot increase under LOC C and
mathematically yeah so let's so
mathematically yeah this is by the way
still the this is just a review
I haven't from yeah but I'll just say
one yeah one thing about it so typically
we're thinking about so I will be
talking about pure entanglement which is
described by vectors in C and right so
the space that I will be looking at is
STM one tens of cm two and so on
there's no CN n this is the space I will
be looking at however and I'll be
looking only at rank one the matrices
typically a physical system the
information about the physical system is
encoded not in a vector but actually in
the matrix which we denote all that is
if if this is H if I call this this is
our Hilbert space which in this case
just a vector space
it goes from H to another H okay so here
it will be a same age for now so this is
this is a density matrix okay
it's a positive semi-definite not
hermitian matrix the tester is one now
what is the LOC c-loc see I go to the
lab and I do something to the system but
I do it locally so LOC C is a completely
positive marketing on
this which we denote sometimes by this
epsilon which is applying this
completely positive map to hope I get
another density matrix let's call it
Sigma now loc see any completely
positive map as a representation as a
sum M sub K or M sub K star I can write
where m is some any complex matrix this
is all matrices here and I sum it over
the case so any completely positive map
has this structure and if it's LOC C
then this structure MK for us for now is
a K tends o some beacon on system that's
the bipartite cases so suppose we have
only two for now so the a is a matrix
acting on this space and the B is any
complex matrix acting on this space and
any allowed operation has this form
that's essentially what is LOC C so
that's not quite true
this is called separable stater of CC is
shown not to be exactly that but you
have to define it operationally so Alice
does the measurements and the result to
Bob or perform based on the outcome of
the measurement based on a but that most
mathematician won't understand that kind
so I think this is the closest I can
come to LOC see but that's too
restrictive so that's not what I'm going
to talk about I'm going to talk about
something which is has some probability
so instead of achieving this with
certainty this represents achieving it
with certainty if I take off this the
son
this is I can achieve each element here
with some probability and that's what we
will consider that's why the group that
will be involved in our in the
characterization of entanglement would
be SSL so the group I'll be looking at
is the SL and four cubits it will be to
see tensile end times depends if we have
n qubits I'll be looking at that that
comes from physics from from the fact
that I don't want to be able to increase
entanglement under local operations so
if I apply an element of this group to
the vectors that I'm writing here in
principle I cannot increase the the
entanglement so that's what really
classify entanglement I know this is
there is a lot more to it it's kind of
in a nutshell how you by the spirit
thing yeah so now for us yeah this is
the this is the it's essentially to
classify the orbits under this group
every orbit is is an entangled state
that has nothing to do with another ball
bit like the entanglement is is just
different that you cannot even compare
so entanglement is not like one quantity
it's actually a hole if we have a
partial yes exactly it's a partial order
exactly so this is what we have this is
for three qubit
so let's look what have we have in three
qubit if I look at as a dis go so four
on three cubits I I'm looking at this
scope and I want to classify it into its
all bits and so I got down to two types
of states the W in the ghz this is under
under this this orbit those are the ones
that we will say genuinely entangled
these ones there are other orbits where
you can see this is a some state between
Alice and Bob the first two qubits and
the third qubit is completely it's a
tensor product II right so we just don't
write Enzo this is completely decent
from this state so those two states are
completely these systems are completely
not entangled that's why these kinds of
patil and the lower hierarchy of
entanglement and this is the most non
entangled state because in every
bipartite card there is no entanglement
in this state and you can see that this
doesn't generate entanglement you cannot
go from here higher so this is the
lowest entanglement this is the middle
and those are the most entangled but
this one in some sense is the generic
one actually in three cubits the rank
two is the generic not the rank three
this one it turns out so this is the
generic one so it's a dense
this is an open then setting in the
space of three cubits okay so this is
what we know about three cubits at
fifteen years ago almost
the tangential variety of the cigarette
yes oh by the way to everyone who don't
know it I'm a physicist not a
mathematician so be aware of that so
it's the set of all the tenses two by
two by two times to find the determinant
zero that's that's hard describe ginger
yeah yeah I wouldn't think about
anything this way but but yeah but it's
true I guess in this case yeah yeah I
already copied my talk so yeah you will
be talking about how the determinant
anything over okay so let's move on a
little bit so now I want to talk about
how we classifying it so we will be
using the company's theory and what I
got right here is so again the pencil
here is just an X okay so there is no
circle don't no need for a circle here
it's just a typo so we're looking at
this group we're looking at this space
and what I did right here is the
company's steering for my purposes okay
so of course you can write the company's
theorem and more general so in this case
we're looking at n cubed this group this
is the local unitary group that I'll be
looking at the lives above this group
and we define a set of critical stage
those critical States those are states
that satisfies this this relation now in
physics we realize this is an inner
product so it's X applying to Phi and
then the inner product of that we find
okay yeah for all X oh I forgot yeah for
all exchanges so then the lighting it in
this scope in the go picture it tells us
that it has the lowest known that those
critical state has the lowest norm and
the most the perhaps non-trivial part of
this campus steering is this the third
part is that device closed if and only
if G Phi as using the is in the
intersection isn't is not okay now from
so those are these are the sets of
critical states now how these states
related to entanglement and what's why
why this is important to us the reason
is is because every element of critical
state a state is critical if and only if
when I look at the bipartite card
between this vector and and the rest of
the system is maximally entangled but
only one not to like a d2 and we can see
it very simply by just to get intuition
where it coming from just suppose that I
have this cube it and it's maximally
entangled with the rest it means I can
write it like that will fight 0 and Phi
1 our token all states so Phi Phi 0 and
Phi 1 are just elements of n minus 1
cube it's okay so it's a big it's a
vector in a it's it's not in dimension -
okay so it's we're looking at C - 10 0
and then we have C to 1000 C - and then
I'm looking at it like that so this is
so Phi Phi 0 and Phi 1 our terminal
States belonging to here okay so these
states belong here and this is the first
one so if we're looking at the first
qubit to get the intuition where it
comes from you can see that if it's
maximally entangled I can write it like
that well these are two orthogonal and
then you can easily check that if you
apply these three power mattresses on
the first qubit here and you do this
inner product between this and this
state you get the
and angle is extremely pathological
condition yeah but this is not maximally
entangled completely okay this is not
what the just notice the difference
between this is not maximally entangled
this is just every qubit is maximally
entangled with the last but not yeah
exactly in physic yeah the interest
exactly the most interesting states like
we've seen before actually does that
very special every they are very non
generic they are highly non generic
let's say and in fact it's even yeah
okay so let's look at the example of for
qubits
so in for to understand this critical
states the folk you [ __ ] again sorry
for the typos here there should be a
line here and again ignore the circle
we're for we have this group we have
this local group and then the set of
critical states can be characterized
very nicely info qubits it turns out
that you can characterize it in terms of
for a four dimensional vector space
where up to local unit Alice we can
write it like that where the I should
define what are these states so what is
side plus I plus so side plus minus is 0
0 plus minus 1 1 and the 5 plus minus or
maybe I'm among once again this is 0 1
typically in quantum information these
are the notations and this is a 0 0 plus
minus 1 so these are the those are the
vectors and what you can see is that
every every critical state up to local
unitary looks like that where we have
this four dimensional space meant by
those follicles so this is a very nice
picture picture it's also tells us that
most of the states are in the orbit of a
where G is this SL so most of the states
here and in some sense the every in
every orbit under and the SL the
critical state is the maximally
entangled state in that orbit everything
else in some sense is less entangled
because it doesn't have because it's not
critical and it doesn't have all these
nice properties okay and I'll skip this
yeah just with the numerology so in this
case we have a 16 dimensional vector
space
well dimensional group and you have a
four dimensional vector space that you
move around that gives you almost
everything yes yes always it's always
true that the critical set if you look
at the orbit of the critical set under
the SL it's always dense
three n dimensional guru and yes yeah
and more there are more states know that
are interesting they are stating the
närcon Allah talk if I'll get the time
and talk about it there are many other
states that actually not here that are
also interesting in for example in the W
state that I were down
it wasn't critical and but what it tells
us that they were is so yes there are
many this also implies essentially the
the SL invalid polynomials there are
four independent as Alan van polynomials
basically okay I'll skip this because I
think I'm much time do I have
oh my gosh okay so let's let me define
so how do we so our goal what I would
like to do is to show you how to we can
actually classify all entangled States
according to the to the to classify all
the orbits the under SN DSL go and we're
looking to do that
I have we defining SL invalid
polynomials which are for simplicity I'm
assuming the dimension is 2 but it
doesn't have to be there can be any
dimension and they don't have all to be
the same but for simplicity right now if
the exposition here I'll assume this
then any function that is a saline
variant is called Ursuline Valiant if
it's wrestling violent and the
diffraction f comes from hn 2 to see you
everything is all of the complex now
this is for the physicist so none of
them are here so I'll skip it but there
are examples how we define SL invariant
basically this Sigma Y maybe I should
write this Sigma Y is this so define the
the anti-symmetric matrix J let's call
it J is the analog of Sigma y 0 1 minus
1 0 I look at this and so an example of
an SL in valhalla no Meah is j x oj
apply to side and here i put the bow bow
in the basis well j looks like that okay
so I'll take the bow here meaning so
it's the dual but after but I then I do
bow on this so I'm taking the complex
conjugation away ok because it has to be
it's a bit linear form yeah so this is
and so that's an example and it's unique
for two qubits is only one is having
variant for three cubits there is also
one it's
Kaleigh out of the terminal and it can
be written like that in terms of the two
if you break it like that
if you break if you take a state in
three cubits so this is a two qubit
state I write it like that
not necessarily normalized here and the
very interior yeah yeah okay so and then
we can go on and there is more examples
and also there is something useful I
will skip I'm out of time and let's go
to distinguishing all the SLO orbit and
let's be now start out so just now I'm
starting my talk I should have started
from here because now I want to talk
about the general case so we have M Q
and Q dates and first of all I want to
show you that actually SL environment
polynomials are not so good for us to
distinguish in the orbits because in
physics we're only interested in
normalized state so suppose that I have
one state this is an element of it's all
bit but the state that I want to compare
it with is a state that is normalized
and it might be different up to some
phase so this is really what we want to
look so I'll say that this state Phi and
this desire in the same old it in the
same physical orbit not mathematically
this is what it means so because we have
this factor here SL environmentally
nominals
you know if I take say you take an SL in
a polynomial of degree K we have this
factor here coming out so SL in van
polynomials by themselves cannot
distinguish the polynomials for us so
what do we do
we're looking at the ratios of course so
it can be shown that the ratio between
two SL invariant polynomials of of of
course that that if they are in the same
orbit this is obvious and
the other way around you have to be
careful first we assume that it's
they'll exist as an example in honor
that is nonzero and if this is satisfied
then we can learn it follows that the
states are in the same orbit yes the
same degree too am a genius polynomial
decay here let's present the degree so
if it if this is hold for all K for
which HK is for any K so whenever this
is possible when when it makes sense I
hope from their context okay so the next
thing is what are the degree what are
the possible degrees of the ESL England
polynomial so now I convinced us that in
order to actually to that actual ESL
invariant polynomials are good even for
this because all we doing is looking at
the large ratios instead of the actual
so they are good to distinguish the
physical SLO City classes that state the
next thing is what the possible degrees
of these polynomials so that's simple if
I take this is an element of the
dimension right H was C and 1 cm 2 cm up
tens of CM and so this is an element
implies that so if I take an element of
so if I'm looking at this state and I
want to calculate what is suppose I have
the polynomial of degree K then because
this if if this is a good of unity that
satisfies this relation it implies that
it's in G and because this is are
selling very polynomials we have this
relation but then I can take it outside
because it's homogeneous of degree K so
we obviously get conditioned on what the
dimension of the Asilomar polynomials
could be and they have to be the LCM of
the different local damage
okay so that's the dimension now how do
we find all of them and the main idea of
how to find all the air selling
Valentino meals it seems like very hard
because it's they going that a number
grows exponentially with the number of
qubits and the number of and the
dimensions the local dimensions so it
seems to be a very difficult task and
that's why we for a long time people
found only they're selling viable
anomalies of four cubits but that's
where it stopped we couldn't go much
beyond the law of some height or
determine some example of a selling
guard polynomials but not finding all of
them and our idea here is the main idea
is rather than looking at all the air
selling run polynomials at once we just
going to look at Justin fix the degree
and find all the a selling Valley no
mercy in a fixed living and that's
remarkably simplifying things a lot so
that's the main essentially the main
idea rather than fixing n we're gonna
fix K okay would be fixed and then if we
then we can define so any poly so now
any polynomial in one polynomial of
degree K I can write it like that and
inner product attends all kind of stairs
and this is in here and and then it
because it is SL invalid polynomial we
require that when I apply G an element
of this G here if I applied K times in
the natural way essentially on V then
its fixes V so this is the standard way
to do these sorts of things and so we
have an SL in the polynomial of degree K
which is gene variant and essentially
therefore what we are interested in is
finding all the fixed point of this
space okay is it so how we do that the
main idea is
because the G here in season is a tender
product and where K is an intertwining
map which is a trivial observation is
this if you look if we taking K copies
of this H n its equivalent of taking K
copies of each one of them separately
and so if I have this nice picture I'm
very proud of that picture and it's
because I try to find a picture for this
the grain is the blue and the red are
different dimensions so suppose we have
h 3 of 3 quantum systems in different
dimensions and I have 4 copies so I'm
interested in degree for polynomials and
what we are just doing is just looking
instead of looking it like that we're
looking at it as 3 copies of the same
dimensions here and what this does in
short is it reduced the problem instead
of finding the fixed vectors of this
space we all we have to do is finding
the fixed vectors of this space and that
is much simpler problems actually why is
not true that gives you a complete list
to some of these may map to 0
nobody I mean you might imagine a fixity
here which is not a tensor fix things
yeah because there is so what it does is
is
they will take care of this okay I'll
keep I'll keep going
okay I'm going okay so to summarize
essentially what we showed is that the
fixed points of these are equivalent to
two DS and so what we need is to find
this and for this we have the show while
duality that tells us how to find the
projection to this essentially and it's
given like that the sum is over all the
permutations the permit permutation
group over K elements and this is the
character of the partition of lambda is
given here because the point is if you
remember what I showed B I told before
is that the degree K is must be
divisible by M and it has to be
divisible but each one of those of those
ends and that's why we can write k like
that so we're looking at this partition
and D lambda is the dimension so we have
this and so that's how it says so
essentially we found out or less Ellen
van polynomials of a fixed given degree
okay the problem is of course what we
don't know is when to stop so if you're
going degree for the same few bits they
all have to be divisible by 2 so it's
degree 4 degree 6 degree 8 degree 10
that well we don't know we also did some
calculations on the dimensions we have
the number of assailing darn polynomials
of degree 2 for n qubits is this 4 4 is
this 4 6 degree 6 is this in five cubits
you can check there is only one as Ellen
van polynomial of degree 6 and we found
it actually just for fun and then
degrees 10 and and we have some nice
program that actually can really up to
the up to if I put in a hundred it gives
it
mathematic I just produce it in few
seconds so it's very nice but the bad
news is of course this is exponentially
buffing in N and K so I mean and we knew
it ahead of time but we can't expect to
find but at least we identified them all
so they all related in this way now I
have a lot more to say well what's the
time oh it's the end of the time so I'll
just say that there are easier way there
are simple constructions that we also
found and I'm not going to say there are
some monogamy of entanglement there is a
lot more I mostly give you a review
today but I'll just summarize that that
essentially selling valent polynomials
can we call them slips they can be used
to classify multiple tight entanglement
that was when I talked about the ratio
because that was very important for
physicists because we needed to look at
the ratio that's really the quantity
that physicists would be interested in
is what is the ratio between nestlings
and polynomials not evaluate so they
essentially it can be for a given degree
we can compute them using the
essentially the characters the number of
slips goes exponentially they also have
the they play an important role in
something called monogamy of
entanglement it's a property that if you
have like three parties like Alice Bob
and Charlie then if Charlie is very
highly entangled with Bob then it has to
be not highly entangled we value and we
confuse with the names but understand
yeah let's go them monogamy
yeah then critical entanglement decay
quickly under local noise I didn't talk
about it I didn't talk about my job is
Asian impartial older J didn't have time
but yeah so you have two different
orbits that both have all the same
values for all the variables that you
cannot distinguish with just invariance
polynomials or maybe doing something or
something yeah like for example if you
are in the now cone so the napkin is
defined as this space that all they are
selling violently normals are zero so
this won't tell you anything about that
so it's not it not it doesn't contain
everything and there is some some even
orbits that we call them they are not
stable that they have some they are kind
of a linear combination of so so so if I
have two vectors and I look at this so
this one is in the null cone and this is
not in the närcon so there they also
what I said is not gonna help you in the
sky so essentially what what I talked
about is in critical state we
distinguish the orbits of the critical
orbits obviously has a critical state
and not fully distinguished ever
but it but they can still I mean if if a
state is not political so if this is if
this is critical but this is not this is
in the null cone then it will still tell
you some things about this unstable I
just got this news network
I don't know it is it related yeah so
yeah so the Nelson it's here it knows
that if we have to bipartite state so
this is we talking about two systems C
and tens of cm if I have C n tens of cm
so I'm looking at vectors here and it
turns out that the LOC C relation is
equivalent so I can go from here to here
by a low C see if and only if there
exist probabilities P I and unit alleys
and some set of unit alleys any unit
Alice not matrices that such that the
reduced density matrix what I talked
about placing the partial trace trace
the B Hill and I traced the be here so I
can tell between the reduced density
matrices of this if they are related
like that then I can go from here to
here and it's if and only if and it's
also known that two matrices to emission
matrices are related like that if and
only if the eigenvalues of a are
modulized by the eigen values of Sigma a
now in the multi-party systems it's very
hard to to do that but we define
something analog to that and I'll just I
won't go into details but I'll just say
that one can go from Taiwan to situ by
separable operation which is very
similar to LOC see a little bit big
in this one if and only if there exists
unit alleys that are in the stabilizer
of of this vector size so there is some
analogy that implies modulation but not
backwards you can't go backwards so it's
it's a more and more restrictive
condition but that's yeah we I can talk
about in more detail sir
yeah critical others have to ask you if
we say this classified all others up to
SL yeah
and yeah I mean in the in the obits it's
yeah it's yeah they mention it but it's
true that the in the critical set if
we're looking at SH su orbits versus D
whatever you can do with that cell you
can do if you can do some transformation
reversal you can do it with the su if
you are if the state is critical yeah
yeah yeah yeah I actually didn't know
its name but I I knew of it yeah
thank you